in today's morning rounds the effort to
make a more trendy hearing aid the new
federal law signed this month could help
to speed up innovations to make devices
more affordable some could also be
available over the counter for the first
time without a prescription tech
companies are now working to transform
the way hearing aids are designed and
marketed john blackstone visited one
startup company with its ear on the
market
[Music]
headphones and earbuds transformed the
way we listen to music now the tech
industry wants to do the same for how
the hearing impaired hear the world it's
been a very difficult
experience for me
k.r liu has worn hearing aids since she
was two and a half years old her devices
today are small and hidden but that
doesn't mean the stigma has disappeared
you wear glasses and it's socially
acceptable you might have five or six
pairs that's a fashion statement why
can't hearing technology be that way liu
works for doppler labs a san
francisco-based startup that hopes to
market a version of its 300 dollar here
one earbuds as an alternative to
standard prescription hearing aids that
cost thousands this industry is going to
be completely disrupted the question is
by who this is for your left ear noah
kraft ceo and co-founder of doppler labs
says the earbuds are not just for those
with hearing loss they can be used to
stream music answer calls and razer
lower sounds around you in a
demonstration room made to sound like a
noisy restaurant so can we really turn
up the restaurant yeah sure craft showed
me how his earbuds and a smartphone app
can help anyone hear better now you're
amplifying and enhancing my speech and
that's essentially what a hearing aid
would do so
these could be hearing aids you got it
an audio sample from doppler also
simulates what it sounds like on an
airplane when the noise filter is
activated
ladies and gentlemen
doppler's product is currently sold in
select stores and online as wireless
earbuds not as a hearing aid but that
could soon change
in august the senate passed a measure
that will allow companies like doppler
to market devices directly to people
with mild to moderate hearing loss no
prescription needed what this
legislation does is it opens the market
to technological leaders to say we're
actually looking at these problems
differently roughly 40 million adults in
the u.s suffer from some hearing loss in
a study earlier this year researchers at
johns hopkins found the rates may nearly
double by 2060. you're going to need
hearing aids audiologist sal marzar
wants more people with hearing loss to
get help but worries self-diagnosing
might in some cases mask a bigger
problem there are many diseases that
create hearing loss and they could be
medically or surgically manageable and
by just going and getting a hearing aid
you will neglect that doppler isn't the
only company that sees huge market
potential
a handful of others have introduced
similar audio enhancing gadgets
everybody's needs are a little different
can you match them with an
over-the-counter product we can do it
better and i say that with full
confidence noah kraft and k.r liu hope
that for those with hearing loss
high-tech ear buds will not just bring
sound
but also acceptance she may be
amplifying the world and i may be
streaming music we're both just using
our ears we just happen to hear the
world differently
for cbs this morning john blackstone san
francisco
i think they're on to something because
it looks like they could become an
accessory i'm torn between making them
invisible or making them really colorful
really cool making them really cool
we know so many people who just refuse
to go there yeah because of vanity
that's good
i want to hear
whatever they can do to help that i'm
for it